alright folks here it is day number 30
of css3 in 30 days if you've made it
this far and you've coded a project or
learned a little bit about css3 each day
for the last 30 days congratulate
yourself pat yourself on the back go do
something exciting celebrate because
this was a big accomplishment for you
and I want to congratulate you
now with all the sweet talk aside we're
gonna build one last project it's gonna
be exciting and let me show you what
that looks like right here so here in
day number 30 we're going to code up a
realistic-looking
illustration style css3 coffee cup the
markup is really easy 4 or 5 dibs the
rest of it is css3 gradients and colors
and shadows and transforms and
positioning and all that sort of stuff
to create this beauty right here look at
that looks like a designer went and
illustrated up a coffee cup in like
illustrator or Photoshop or something
like that and we just plopped it on the
screen but these are not images
whatsoever it's not even an SVG graphic
this is straight-up css3 now just to
show you what's going on we have the
entire coffee cup right here so this
circle is one element and we have a
bunch of gradients going on to create
this shadow effect this bevel some
highlights and then it gets darker as it
goes deeper into the cup within here we
have the actual coffee or the brew and
this ring on the outside is the crema as
a coffee snob I guess you could call me
I that I wanted to include this the
crema is when you pull an espresso shot
and there is that thick or thin layer of
creamy coffee on the top it's this crema
is what it is and it's a little bit
bitter it's gotten a lot of flavor and
it typically is a sign of a good
espresso shot being pulled if you let it
settle for a while the crema
settle around the edges revealing the
coffee and under it so that is the outer
ring of what is remaining of the crema
this is a very subtle black - very very
dark brown gradient going from top left
to bottom right just to give it a little
bit more depth because right here we
have this ring this this light ring this
reflection and that's as if the light
were shining from the top right sorry
the top left down that's why the coffee
is darker here the shadow is being cast
by the rim of the coffee cup and it gets
a little bit lighter here as the as the
light source reflects down into the cup
and onto the coffee so there is this
ring right here as that reflection
giving it depth and a little bit of a
gradient so those are the two elements
there we have one more element right
here and it's just simply a handle just
to hold your coffee so let's jump into
our code editor and see how simple or
maybe difficult it is to come up with
this sort of css3 all right over here my
code editor we have day number 30 css3
coffee go ahead and download that and
fire it up in your code editor of choice
we have the index sandbox and final of
course final is there for your reference
if you have any problems and you want to
refer to something it should be down in
there and sandbox that CSS is where
you're gonna code things up index is our
basic HTML file this is the marker we're
going to be using that is all the market
but takes to give us the base to build
our css3 illustration style coffee cup
so we have the coffee wrapping
everything that div and then we have a
div with a class of handle div with the
class of coffee cup and a div with class
of brew pretty self-explanatory over in
our sandbox let's get started the first
thing we're gonna do is we're going to
select the class of coffee and we're
just gonna give it position:relative
because we're going to be doing some
absolute positioning within this now
we're going to select the handle and
let's just start off simple the handle
is really easy to code and
we just want to get that one out of the
way so let's start off with linear
gradients well actually no let's start
off with position:absolute and we're
gonna go width 127 pixels heights 50
pixels I've done these measurements
before so I'm not just coming up with
them off the top of my head and we're
gonna give it a border radius of 50
pixels so it's a bit rounded on the
outside edge and then what we're gonna
do is give it a box shadow of 5 pixels 0
1 pixel 0 and then rgba we're gonna go
200 200 200
and then 0.8 just to give it a little
bit of a subtle shadow on the far right
hand side so this is 5 pixels on the
x-axis so it's gonna go over 5 pixels 0
on the y 1 pixel blur and then 0 for the
spread okay save that and let's see what
we've got okay so we have a shape here
but we have no I could just say maybe I
would give it a background white so you
can see it so there we go we have the
shape but we need that gradient to give
it that kind of realistic style so this
is what we're gonna go
background-image:linear-gradient and
bear with me here
we're gonna go 180 degrees that's the
angle at which you want the gradient to
go and this is what we're gonna add some
values okay so we're gonna say RGB this
is going to be 200 200 200 and then at
at the 5% color stop we're going to add
another RGB here and this one is going
to be 255 255 255 and that's at the 50%
color stop and if I were to stop there
let's see what happens so we're going to
have a little bit of a dark up here it's
going to get lighter to this white right
here 255 is white 200 is just a like
kind of a light gray and then now we're
going to keep going
let's go down below this and we're gonna
say RGB we're gonna add another 200 200
200 and that's gonna be at the 95% color
stop leave it at that that should give
us
oh sorry RGB not RGB a save that leave
it at that there we go we've got our
shape now it's going to be over at the
right side we'll worry about that once
we get to that part so let's carry on
now that we've got the handle complete
let's style up the actual coffee cup so
we're gonna say coffee - cup and we're
gonna say position:relative we're gonna
go with it's gonna be 462 pixels and the
height will be the same for 62 pixels
we're gonna give it a border radius of
50% so it gives us that perfect circle
we're gonna go zette index 3 so it's
above the handle and anything below is
that index of 3 and now we're gonna give
it a box shadow of 10 pixels 35 pixels
30 pixels 7 pixels and rgba I'll show
you what this looks like in a sec it's
gonna be yeah well it could be 50 but to
be specific 49 49 49 that's the color
I'd decided in Photoshop okay save that
okay so you see the outline here and
then the shadow it's casting so you see
that that's the light source it's coming
from that sort of angle so that's what
we want to go for right there and now
this is the fun part this is where we
create a radial gradient this is gonna
be a fun one we're gonna have to create
the shadows and the outlines of the
porcelain cup itself and then the the
crema the ring the ring of crema is what
we're going to be creating here all in
one background image alright radial
gradients first thing is going to be 50%
and 50% that is basically a center
center we want the gradient to come from
the center outwards is
we're doing here , we're gonna go down
to the next line only for readability
purposes here and we're gonna say RGB
it's gonna be 14 7 and 0 this color is
gonna be at the 65% color stop so 65%
from the center towards the edge all
right and let's add another line here
RGB and that's gonna be 185 144 and 18
and that is gonna be at the 75% color
stop let's see what this gives us okay
so now you can start to see what's going
on so we added our first color stop at
65% and it's a near black it's kind of a
dark dark brown this RGB color right
here at the 65% color stop and then at
75% we're going to transition into this
color which is that golden crema color
so over here from the center and this is
the full circle here so 65% of the way
in so right there we got that dark brown
and then from at the 75% color stop
right here we have this golden color so
in between is the transition so that's
how that works now let's keep going
because we do have more to add okay the
next line is RGB and this color will be
129 129 129 and then also at the 75%
color stop so it's gonna be a hard line
let's see what that gives us okay so now
we're it's gonna cut off right here at
the 75% color stop hard because it's
right at this there's no transition like
this one from this color to this color
it just stops right at the same spot so
this is a grey and we're gonna actually
transition that into a white now so
let's go back and we're gonna say RGB
and this one will be 255 255 255 which
is just white and that's at the 95%
color stop so that's gonna transition
let's see what that gives us okay now
you can start to see how this is
starting to take shape into a cup so now
what I want to do for the last color at
the 100% markers just fade it back down
a little
to gray so it has that bevel I don't
have a coffee cup on me but the the
light source will also cast a shadow
around the outside just to make it look
like it's rounding back down on the
outside of the porcelain cup or whatever
material coffee cups are made of so one
more here we're gonna say our GB and
that will be 161 161 and 161 at the 100%
color stop and then just finish it off
there like that and now you could see
that it grounds it back out at the
outside so now it's giving us that nice
shape all right and now what we're gonna
do I think that's all for the coffee cup
and the that base layer of coffee with
the crema now what we want to do is
actually have the brew so we have over
here we're gonna say brew and this is
the coffee itself it's me really simple
we're just going to make it look a
little bit more have a little bit more
depth we're gonna give that coffee an
actual gradient so this element is going
to be position:absolute as well we're
gonna say width is 316 pixels by the
same in height the zet index will be 4
we're going to say box-shadow
is 5 pixels on the X 5 pixels on the y 0
is blur and 0 as spread rgba this is 252
by 2 32 by 185 and 0.5 as in the Alpha
Channel so save this I'm not sure you'll
see it anywhere yet here it is so you
can see just a square so this is going
to give us that this is going to be that
outline that
well you can see down here this outline
it's gonna be this but because it's uh
it's a rectangle we need to round that
out so that's gonna be quite simple all
we need to do is save order radius and
that's gonna be 50% save that that will
round it out you'll see it here and
somewhere down where it shouldn't be so
we're gonna position that in the correct
spot so let's say top 50% and then left
well it's gonna be about 70 pixels in
save that okay so something is going on
here
okay so 50 I went 50% down so this is
the element itself and 150 percent down
for that elements which is here so the
top of the top left of it will be
somewhere around here okay so that means
I'm going to actually use the transform
property we did this a few times in this
course we're gonna do the translate Y
and just say negative 50% relative to
that top position and it's gonna bring
it up 50% and match it perfectly in the
spot where we want it to be like that
now I'm looking at it here it's a little
bit different than this one and okay I
think what we're gonna do now this might
change a bit now once we add a color so
I'm gonna actually add a gradient in
here so let's go and say background
image we're gonna do a linear gradient
and this is gonna look like this we're
gonna go 140 degrees so that angle top
public top left to bottom right ish and
now we're gonna go like this we're gonna
say RGB this is gonna be zero zero zero
and that's just flat black at the 0%
color stop we're gonna add another line
here RGB this is gonna be 52 26 and 0 be
pretty darkest at Brown at the 100%
color stop very very simple save it and
there we go that's more like it so the
problem was we didn't have a background
image so if I were to remove this style
altogether and then check out our crema
it doesn't line up properly and that's
because our circle wasn't filling out
this area so if I put the background
much back it actually cleans it up quite
nice it's exactly what I'm looking for
beautiful
all right and one last thing is just put
this handle back we need to put that
handle back where it belongs and then we
are done with our css3 coffee cup I hate
to say it we are and then after that
we're done with the course but let's not
talk about that right now I'm gonna cry
it sounded a little bit like Peter
Griffin pre-k a crafting that was a
pretty bad impression actually okay so
now what we're gonna do is put the
handle in its correct position and
that's gonna be simple let's just say
chop 50% and write 40 pixels in from the
right save that okay so it's a little
bit too low because the top of this is
at the fifth at 50% of its parent so
we're actually gonna bring that up to
the perfect center and that's going to
be using the transform translate Y
negative 50%
and save that it's gonna Center it
perfectly
that looks amazing let's compare it to
the final identical looking absolutely
fantastic Wow congratulations everybody
on completing css3 in 30 days you just
did 30 days of css3 building projects
learning more about css3 and in general
just leveling up your front-end web
developer game Congrats on that I loved
that you hung out with me for this past
month I hope you're not too sick of me
because I certainly hope that this is
just the beginning of our journey
together if you found any value in this
course share with a friend share it with
a family member hecqs share it with your
grandmother or your dad it doesn't
matter anyone you feel would get value
from this course send them this way and
let's see if we can't make a web
developer out of them too again thank
you so much you're the best have a great
day and I will hopefully see you in
another course on the flip side and as
always happy coding
[Music]
PJ Griffin Peter Griffin Peter MacKay
there's a family guy lucky there's a man
who positively can who
bah-bah-bah-bah-bah-bah half and cry
he's aa family bum Peter alright I'm a
crazy person